- [Instructor] We're told
that the nth partial sum
of the series from n
equals one to infinity
of a sub n is given by.
And so the sum of the first
n terms is n squared plus one
over n plus one.
And they want us to figure out,
what is the actual seventh term?
And, like always, pause this
video and see if you can
figure it out on your own before
we work through it together.
All right, so, one way to
think about it is: a sub seven,
let's think about how that
relates to different sums.
So, if we have a sub one,
plus a sub two, I'll just
go all the way, a sub
three, plus a sub four,
plus a sub five, plus a
sub six, plus a sub seven.
So, if I were to sum all
of these things together,
that--this entire sum--that
would be s sub seven.
And if I wanted to figure out a sub seven,
well I could subtract from that.
I could subtract out the
sum of the first six terms.
I could subtract out s sub six.
So, once again, what am I doing
here, what is my strategy?
I know the formula for the
sum of the first n terms.
I can use that to say, okay,
I can figure out the sum
of the first seven terms.
That's gonna be the sum of all of these.
And then I can use that
same formula to figure out
the sum of the first six
terms, and the difference
between the two, that's
going to be our a sub seven.
So, another way of saying
what I just said is that
a sub seven is going to be the
sum of the first seven terms,
minus the sum of the first six terms.
And if you were doing this
problem on your own you wouldn't
have to write it out this way,
I just wrote it out this way,
hopefully making this statement
a little bit more intuitive.
Well, what is this going to be?
Well, s sub seven, the sum
of the first seven terms,
we just, wherever we see an
n, we replace it with a seven.
So it's going to be
seven squared plus one,
over seven plus one and from
that we are going to subtract
s sub six, the sum of the first six terms.
Well, that's going to
be six squared plus one,
or six plus one.
And from here we just have to
do a little bit of arithmetic.
So, this is going to be
seven squared plus one,
this is 49 plus one so
that is 50 over eight.
And this is six squared plus one,
that's 37,
over seven.
So, we want to find a common denominator
between eight and seven.
That would be 56.
So this is going to be something over 56,
minus something else over 56.
Now, to go from eight to
56 I multiply by seven,
so I need to multiple the
numerator by seven as well.
50 times seven is 350.
And then, this second fraction,
I multiple the denominator
by eight to get to 56,
so I have to multiply
37 times eight.
Let's see 37 times eight is going to be
240 plus 56, so that is 296.
And so this is going to be equal to--
so I have a denominator of
56, 350 minus 296 is 54.
So, it's 54/56.
And if we wanted to
reduce this a little bit,
before we rewrite it
maybe in a simpler form,
we're rewriting the same value.
This would be, let's see, could
we write it as 27 over 28?
Let's see, is that about?
Yep, that's about as
simplified as we can get.
There you go, that's what
a sub seven is, it's 27/28.
The difference between the
sum of the first seven terms,
and the sum of the first six terms.